what do you make of cali waldrip who
said that you concocted an
abduction story
and i'll just read this quote i happened
across your referring to michael shermer
your assessment
of travis walton's alleged abduction
aboard a ufo in 1975. your suspicion
that it was a hoax is completely correct
i know these you can respond to this
shortly travis and i were in junior high
school back together
together back in the early 60s and he
was constantly dreaming up schemes to
deceive folks
that a ufo was visiting
i i haven't seen him in decades and
i reminded him of that in 2006 via email
he changed the subject
i found the online bio
suggesting that we weren't in the same
grade school were the same age but his
bio lists in five so there's various
assertions there how would you respond
to that
like i say people who knew you are eager
to say i've got the inside story
well
he's got some
amazing tales um
himself
he was my best friend
and uh it was actually his idea to
put up a hot air balloon or something
but uh
he became an fbi agent
and
the only contact i've had with him was
years ago and he was describing how he
was basically
ducking and dodging around the planet to
avoid being assassinated in connection
with his previous work his previous job
i don't know maybe it's true sounds kind
of wild though
but uh he's definitely exaggerating
anything that was said between us like i
said people love to get attention
uh
i know this guy you know i'll tell you
the inside story
you know he's not in a position to add
anything positive so it's great to
attack your best friend but uh whatever
and you two had a falling out
no we just um you know i moved yeah
to a different city you called him your
best friend
you mean prior or even now
during our during our junior high years
you know we hung out together all the
time but uh i guarantee you ufos were
not a constant topic of conversation you
mentioned something about a hot air
balloon
um
this is something he's saying
that i said but uh i only remember him
suggesting such a thing
but uh
it's terrible somebody would come out
there and attack you like that
do you think that he just wants
fame himself or money or what
well just like i said you know i'm the
guy that's gonna i got the inside story
i know this person you know
it's like the guy who says i called him
first before i called my family
it's um in that case not attempting to
do any harm just to attach yourself
to something that's got a lot of
attention i mean there were three or
four
girls that i had dated who had some
stories to tell when everybody's talking
about that guy
and uh
things that weren't true
and this
email communication he references in
2006 he said he brought it up to you
i'm unsure exactly what he's referring
to i assume he means that you were
quote-unquote trying to deceive and so
on but then you change the subject do
you know what he's referring to
do you recall this
oh kelly waldrop
this i'll just give you the quote he
said i'm actually reminded i reminded
him of this referring to what we just
spoke about in 2006 via email and he
simply changed the subject not wanting
to crack his golden egg i suppose
that's what kelly said what i said was i
don't remember you had an idea like that
he was accusing me of an idea um
but
like i say it's the same
same thing you know
he's using my prior friendship with him
to
elevate himself here
does he in any way speak to
seven people passing police lie detector
test does he speak to
the effect of radiation on tree growth
does he uh you know any of those kinds
of things the guy's an fbi agent or a
former fbi agent so he should um
resort to evidence and uh the facts of
the case
don't attack the
let's address the facts when you can't
address the facts
attack the person so
that's what's happening does it hurt you
because he's a former friend of yours i
imagine that
if that was me i would be
not only offended but
saddened
are you so used to it now
well of course it's uh it's sad you know
and i'd always thought about
contacting him
because i'd heard some the story
secondhand from somebody
that i worked with at the paper mill
that he had said something like that
and uh
kind of uh fell in him in on the details
that
don't don't be jumping to conclusions
guy
but apparently he has
to each his own